and I'm here with David Sater lead
writer for Dragon Age to lead writer for
Dragon Age Origins and Dragon Age novels
the man of many traits what can you tell
us about Dragon Age 2 I just played it
it's fantastic what influenced the jump
what changes did you make and why well
the idea was to give it a unifying art
style origins look great but we thought
we could make it look better make it
look like a distinct game across say in
all the areas we wanted to establish a
framing narrative so we're telling the
story instead of like beginning to end
you're jumping into the most important
moments of the character's life and that
allows us to do a couple things allows
us to be reactive so rather than waiting
till the end of the game to here in the
epilogue about the results of some of
your decisions you can see the world
evolved according to your choices and
the combats we want to want you to
retain the tactical feel so you'd feel
like you're you're jumping between your
party members and deciding how to how to
how to make them act in combat but we
want to make it more responsive that
rather than having a character sort of
shuffle up and it's initiate their
attack sequence they jump into combat or
they're reacting immediately when you
press a button so you're not sitting in
the background watching it all happen
you're actually part of the fun yeah how
about Dragon Age Origins when Dragon Age
2 comes out is Dragon Age Origins just a
dead game at that point it was still
downloadable content we're releasing our
last piece of DLC for Dragon Age Origins
as witch hunt follows the character of
Morgan finding out what happened to her
sort of ties up the story of the warden
and then the work to her Dragon Age 2
we're moving on to a new hero and a new
part of the world from but from what
I've played absolutely that's ok that's
it's ok to move to Dragon Age 2 is there
anything else you want to add like
anything you want to say you want to get
out there for the fans we're looking
forward to see how they react I mean
Dragon Age Origins was a fantastic game
it had ever written an incredible
reception among the fans and the thing
is is that when you as a developer
you're done there's always things you
think you can do you can do better you
can try to do better we don't want to
sit on our laurels
to us the Dragon Age world is our main
is our main character
and we want to introduce to put the
players to more of it it almost seems
like if you're a fan of good stories
rather than games you'll enjoy Dragon
Age 2 I mean do you agree yeah I think
we would expand that to that there's a
little bit more to the action as well
but just because action action is pumped
up doesn't mean we don't have the same
Bioware focus on a solid story I love it
it's absolutely everything I love in a
game and I'm sure is everything you love
in a game - thank you very much
congratulations on everything